حسنًا،
يشعر الجميع بالفزع من العنف
بغض النظر عن الجانب الذي تنتمي إليه، فهو أمر
فظيع ولكنه
مجرد نوع من التذكير بمدى
الكراهية الموجودة على كلا الجانبين
أحيانًا ومن الصعب عدم الشعور
بالمسؤولية أحيانًا عن جزء منه.
الطريقة التي
نتصرف بها كدولة تحرض أحيانًا على الكثير
من الكراهية على الجانب الآخر ولا أستطيع أن أعرف
أنني لا أستطيع إلقاء اللوم عليهم على الرغم من أنني
لا أعتقد أن العنف هو الحل
، نشعر أحيانًا أنه لا
مفر من ذلك  سوف ينزعج الناس
ويتصرفون بطرق معينة لأنه ربما
لا يكون لديهم خيارات أخرى
وأعتقد أن هذا ما
يعتقدونه ولهذا السبب يتصرفون بهذه الطريقة، فمن
المروع أن يفقد الناس
على كلا الجانبين
حياتهم بسبب هذا  لكن اه، كما
تعلم، أشعر بمسؤولية كبيرة عن
الأشياء التي نقوم بها في بلادنا في
حكومتنا، لا أستطيع أن أتخذ
القرارات ولكن أتمنى أن أكون مسؤولاً
في الخارج